zach was 11 he's our youngest he he
asked me for you know if i was going to
die
finish me off
as facebook's vice president for europe
the middle east and africa nikki is one
of the most powerful women working in
tech facebook is this huge company the
prospect of leading so many regions is
there any element of what the [ __ ] am i
doing here you don't climb everest you
get to base camp one and that's your
thing certainly in chaotic moments it's
like what are the things you can control
in order to either get out of the chaos
or to hit the north star
so this meta shift people are
understandably scared do you have any
concerns that we're taking away what it
is to be a human i think it's an
important question i think
three years into your career at facebook
and then you get some awful news
i got the diagnosis that i had
follicular lymphoma which is an
incurable blood cancer so we gathered
the kids on the sunday morning
i couldn't i just couldn't get the words
out
[Music]
and i told my story on world cancer day
so many people sharing having a similar
disease but we're scared to show that
because it was a sign of weakness i mean
it sounds ridiculous but there are still
companies where that sort of behavior is
happening we often don't put the
discipline into our personal lives that
we do in our work lives and often our
work lives are dictated by others
these things aren't mutually exclusive
so without further ado
i'm stephen bartlett and this is the
diary of a ceo i hope nobody's listening
but if you are then please keep this
yourself
[Music]
nicola
you've had
an extremely extraordinary career i've
followed you for many many years for
many many years i think about six or
seven years throughout my career
and i've watched and i've also gone back
and looked at the previous
21 odd years you spent in advertising in
agencies because my background is in
advertising and agencies
my first question is when you think
about
why you why you were able to lead that
career
what are the circumstances of your early
years that went into shaping
who you became and the success you then
saw for the next
30 40 years of your career
well first can i just say i'm so excited
to be here in your dining room and
having um having this conversation with
you and fear of this turning into a
great big loving i've been following you
too
so um yeah i couldn't be more thrilled
to have this conversation
that's a great big question to um to
start with i think
from a very early age
i was always very curious i was always
that kid that was putting their hand up
and just going well hang on what about
can i ask a question
and to be honest it didn't play so well
in school
um the school that i was at at the time
really just wanted like a cookie cutter
that you came in you learnt by ro you
passed your exams and
i i wanted always to just push the
question a little bit understand a
little bit more
and i think that kind of desire for
knowledge that curiosity
wanting to know what might happen has
probably been a part of shaping who i am
do you know where that came from that
curiosity did it come from somewhere did
you have brothers and sisters
yeah i um
so i grew up in manchester i have um
a fantastic family a family of two
brothers parents all connected
grandparents in and out of the house
every single day
and
my mom worked my grandma worked and so
my north star at the time was just kind
of a very busy household people coming
and going but people always there for
one another people supporting
and a belief i think that anything was
possible my parents were caterers
and they used to do functions for
um extraordinary people celebrities
prime ministers
and so i grew up just seeing that even
extraordinary people are just people i
was a grafter i was working as a
waitress
for them and so i saw that and i saw
people and i think if you take the fear
away out of people however successful
they are i think it allows you to think
yourself about what you can learn from
from them and then what you might be
able to apply to yourself
were you a confident child yes i was yes
what evidence do you have of that
if you look back on my school reports
talks too much i think if you're not
confident you probably don't talk too
much asks too many questions
um
i wasn't i wasn't fearful i wasn't
afraid
it's funny because as you say when
you're younger those things are often
looked down upon even the phrasing of
that too many questions
yeah and especially for a woman or a
girl at the time i remember um
yeah there was a really particular
incident when i was
15 it was the
parents evening where you just before as
it was o levels that was the last year
of o levels gcses and
you go in the um dining room and with
both my parents from teacher to teacher
and this was a really important moment
for me as a child where the latin
teacher
literally started to shout at my parents
and told them that if i didn't change my
personality that i was never going to
get on in life can you imagine being
told that at 15
and it hadn't been such a good parents
even i'll be honest but i saw something
in my dad that day that
really has always stuck with me because
he turned around and he turned to her
and he said i want to be really clear he
said
i think it'll be my daughter's
personality that gets her on in life
not what she does with latin
and with that he was like we're off
and so i went with my parents and we
left but i just remember thinking he's
got my back he sees something in me that
she doesn't and it was a real seminal
moment for me as a as a child growing up
what was that latin teacher referring to
when she said when she was talking
negatively about your personality what
was it in your personality she didn't
like she didn't like the questioning she
didn't like me and
really trying to get to grips not just
learning the the language by rote but
actually understanding much more about
what the romans were doing and what you
know what we learnt as a result but that
wasn't her job her job was to teach her
the language not to teach us more on the
history and that side of it and i was
really interested in that and
yeah she didn't like that at that age
what if i'd asked you what you wanted to
be when you grew up what would you have
said to me
that time i would have probably said
an actress
so
yeah i was i was always in the plays i
was doing performances and
i was told at school that i wasn't very
good i wasn't clever i wasn't going to
pass my exams
with hindsight i think there was
probably some anti-semitism that i
experienced at school
and a few particular incidents that
stick out but and so i thought my life
was going to be on the stage
a few particular incidents that stick
out yeah i had um
i'm religious and i observed the sabbath
and
that meant in the winter months that i
would go home early from school
and we had a couple of teachers that
would always insist on starting the new
topics on a friday afternoon
and when my parents and they could have
started the topics and you know who
starts new topics on a friday afternoon
that's not a good thing for anybody you
know it's the end of the week people are
tired
my parents went in um and to ask about
it
and they were told very clearly that if
my parents insisted on taking me out
what you know that was our problem not
theirs
and um
yeah i
i that was one thing that i had that
stuck in my mind and another thing i had
i had an english teacher who
um
used to mark me down
and
my marks were really low i was like two
out and three out of ten and i was in a
good school and these were not my marks
and my parents again my parents
there's a kind of a thing here that they
they were backing me
they actually took my english book to um
one of my brother's teachers and said
what do you think of this work and they
said we don't understand the marks these
are the marks of a of a child that you
know this is an a student
but my confidence was so smashed by
these teachers telling me i wasn't good
i wasn't smart that i you know didn't
think that i would maybe even do a
levels never mind going to university at
that time which was kind of the normal
for that school
and
as it turned out i i left school at that
school at 16 and went on to college
and i got an a in my o level in english
and actually decided to read english for
a did a levels got an a
and actually went to university and read
english and you know did an english
degree
i actually went back to my school
and i think about this now and i can't
believe i did it when i got my a and my
place at university i went back
um to the school to that english teacher
and so i rocked up and i said to her
i've come to see you and she was like as
you can imagine quite shocked and she
goes why are you here i said i've come
to tell you that you could have
destroyed my life
and the power that you wielded on others
really could destroy and i said you know
you really came close with that with me
and taking away a dream of mine that
might never have been realized because i
always loved reading and passionate
about books
and
i just needed to tell her that
and i felt better for telling her that
never saw her again
what did she say
she just looked at me shocked and you
know i think back now with the uh the
benefit of age it was quite a shocking
thing to go and tell somebody
that you know their own biases and
prejudices and the power that they wield
could destroy a life
um
you know in comparison with the best of
teachers that it can inspire and lift up
and and to make you something
make you believe in yourself more that
wasn't some of the experiences i had
from some of my teachers
more broadly what does that say about
the
education system because i i mean i feel
a similar way i was
always did bad in school
there was two lessons that i would never
miss which was business and psychology
but other than that i would not attend
so and it wasn't i wasn't a rude kid you
know i went back and i've spoken at the
school multiple times now and when i go
there they say you were a really nice
guy but a useless student and because of
that the sort of implicit message of
of being a useless student um and the
idea that the a grade people are going
to be rich and successful and happy and
then everyone else you're gonna have to
settle for something else you're not
gonna go for a kid that's such an easy
narrative to believe it's almost amazing
when you hear that someone went through
that and they didn't believe that story
at such an impressionable age
is there something that we can do to
remove
i don't know
grades altogether or to stop people like
you who went on to have these phenomenal
careers potentially falling through the
net because of one bad teacher or one
bad grade or believing a narrative about
themselves based on
any of the above so i think it
that's a big question and i think there
is there's a lot in there to unpack but
i think having people believe in you at
a young age
is really important and not everyone is
as fortunate to have a family that is as
loving and as supportive as mine is
and so
people look to people like teachers kids
look to teachers to be those people for
them and on the whole i think teachers
do a phenomenal job i mean a really
truly extraordinary job
but some kids slip through
and i think it's on all of us to think
about what more we can do to be able to
help kids to
really realize and their full potential
because you're right how many more are
out there that could be doing the most
extraordinary things if someone just
says to them i believe in you i got you
i think you could do this
at what point then did you
choose advertising
this one's really simple so i
went through university doing um i
actually did english and theater study
so i was acting and actually had a place
at drama school um
at central school of speech and drama
it's a great school but i you know i
shared that i'm religious and i observed
the sabbath and i quickly realized that
you know a life on the stage is not it's
not very
you know compatible with you know
wanting to observe the sabbath so
i also saw that friends of mine who were
um acting
were pretty miserable because there's so
much luck involved you know they were
trying to get the equity cards they were
working in remote parts of the uk
trying to you know get a break
and i just didn't want to roll the dice
and have so much of my life dependent on
luck and they were great actors and
great actresses
and at the time i had a friend who was a
year older than me guy called neil
marcus who
had got a job in advertising in london
and i was
wow i've never heard of such a job i
didn't know anybody growing up in
manchester that worked in the creative
industries it wasn't a known thing that
and it wasn't a thing in my school from
my careers advice that they gave you
that there were such jobs and yeah i'd
always love the creative industries i
love theater i love you know drama i
love fashion i love film i loved all
these things so
when i heard what he did and that you
know you could get paid to do such a
thing i was like that's the thing i want
to do so that's how i got embarked on it
and then i did my research which back in
the um
the early 90s comprised of going to a
library and getting hold of you know the
the magazines the trade magazines and
working my way through them to
understand the great agencies and so i
applied uh as a graduate trainee to get
on a scheme and i got into uh bottle
bogle hegerty which was the one i wanted
to go to acting drama theater all these
things
in hindsight
has the skills that taught you played a
role in your career
yeah definitely i think all everything
that you do makes you who you are
um and so
i actually think the skills of acting is
something that all kids benefit from
because it gives you confidence it gives
you confidence to make a presentation it
gives you confidence to make a pitch
these are some really vital things when
it comes to
you know working in business
acting also gives you the skills of
working in a team you're relying on each
other who's going to finish the the
lines the you know the the makeup artist
the you know the directors the producers
you're all working as one um to be able
to come together and realize the
potential so yeah definitely all those
things definitely helped
you spent that the next sort of 20 years
from that first sort of grad was it a
grad internship yeah no yeah spent the
next 20 years working in advertising
um
interesting industry to work and you
stayed in there probably a lot longer
than i think i could have because you
know there's lots especially when you're
working agency side there's a lot to
deal with you rose within that industry
very quickly as well
but when you think about that period of
your career what did that really teach
you in terms of yourself leadership
skills
and everything in between what was the
so many things so definitely taught me
leadership skills and
you know you start early on working for
others but then you as you rise through
the ranks then people work for you and i
was always very keen to learn from
others that were doing it and i you know
i spent the first 12 years in
advertising working for bottle bogle and
hegerty so i learnt from some of the
very best crafts people
in the industry both from the business
side and actually the creative side as
well
i remember when i when i left there and
i was taking on my first really senior
position at gray that i actually went to
see someone called stevie spring who was
a woman i hugely admired now as a dear
friend to ask her what i should do what
advice did she have
and she said to me um
nikoi you really need to think about
every aspect of when you're talking to
people not just what you're saying but
how you're saying it and how you're
using your body language and other
things as well because people are going
to judge you they're going to pick up on
everything that you say and i thought
that that was good advice that nobody um
had ever shared before it was also the
first sort of time that i started to get
360 feedback on
and so that i could learn about how
others perceive me because how you think
of yourself in your head is very
different to how other people can
perhaps think about you so it was
actually making sure that i was
developing the muscle of leadership as
well as i was going through uh the
different roles that i have so yeah it
took taught me a huge amount what were
some of your weaknesses in that early
phase of your career that you that you
really had to work hard to overcome you
talked a bit about body language and i'm
not sure if that was a weakness and then
um was there anything that you you
initially struggled with being in that
agency
um sphere working for someone else yeah
i think um
not trusting my instincts
trying sometimes to be something i
wasn't you know bbh in the 90s was super
cool you know everybody was wearing 501
jeans and white t-shirts and honestly
that wasn't a really good look on me
and so
trying to emulate what others were doing
rather than just trusting me and
actually having the confidence now this
has sounded a weird one because i
already told you that i thought i was a
confident person
but having
and and i've really realized that this
is something that women do more which is
having an exhaustive conversation in
your head before you get your point out
and then the conversation's moved on and
you've missed it or someone else has
made the point and not realizing that i
had a seat at the table because people
were interested in what i had to say and
not to be so fearful not to get those
points out so
that is definitely a skill i owned as we
as i kind of went through my career why
do you think that that issue is more um
more prevalent in women
i think it's a fear of getting it wrong
being seen as being stupid um
yeah i think that i think those are
things that you know we're challenged on
um from a young age and it's something
that
you know if i could go back i would
definitely
speak up more i would share my voice
more i would
you know bring my opinions to the table
i think those i think women do struggle
with that and certainly talking with
women about this issue i you know
especially if i'm talking to younger
women they're nodding away and it's like
just put that imposter syndrome away
it's really not a good thing it doesn't
help any of us
you in that period if i'm correct you
you kind of went through three different
agencies yeah
started at that first one that i cannot
pronounce you went to gray which i can
pronounce
and then kamarama yeah kamarama yeah
um was the third one
why did you move every time what was the
reason for you to move on the first time
i moved was because
i'd been there 12 years
i looked up above me and all the people
that had been my bosses 12 years earlier
were still all my bosses and were always
going to be my bosses so i kind of
reached a point where i really didn't
think i was learning as much as as i
could and should and actually started to
think about maybe there's a life outside
advertising
and then actually it was somebody else
that came to me a guy called gary lace
came
and said look you're at the coolest
agency
on the planet i'm just coming to gray as
a change management kind of mission i
want you to be on that mission with me
and he goes i know people will sort of
laugh because you're at the coolest and
this one isn't but wouldn't it be
amazing if we could do that and i love
that vision because i thought yeah why
would i swap one great agency for
another great agency where's the
learning
um that curiosity thing again right and
and so i went and did that and honestly
that was one of my steepest learning
curves as from a leadership perspective
um and from a business perspective how
we changed that agency around in the
five years um that i was there and then
it was another kind of moment of
serendipity where um had been at gray
for five years it had been independent
and then it sold to wpp so the change
was kind of coming
and i got a call from a guy called ben
bilbaul who was one of the founders of
karmarama and said would you could i
have a cup of coffee
and i said yeah definitely and i always
whenever people ask me that i would
always say yes i was like you never know
interesting things always happen when
you when you meet interesting people
ben's interesting
so i go and meet ben and i was totally
hoodwinked because the other founders of
the agency were there sid and dave
i was like okay what's this and they
said oh we're here to see if you want to
be our fourth partner
i was like oh i didn't see that one
coming at all
and that had very much been a boutique
business a lifestyle business they
wanted to significantly grow it and so
i i joined the agency and
the day i joined there were 12 people
sat round the table and the day i left
there were 250 in five years
didn't it sell to accenture yeah i did
um a couple of years ago it did
so that first that first was it eight
and a half years at that agency that i
can't pronounce tell me the name you can
just say bbh
12 years 12 years later which is a long
time in ad in adland which is a long
time in anything yeah i guess a lot of
people especially i don't know if it's i
don't have the data but these days i
think amongst our generation the thought
of doing 12 years at one place is quite
inconceivable why did you do 12 years
there and
would it not have made more sense to
because there's often this narrative
that if you swing more from job to job
you can get higher faster would it have
not made more sense to just you know do
a couple of years then move on
so there was a lot going on in my life
in that 12 years so i got married i had
three of our four children while i was
there and also i absolutely loved the
agency and the job that i did so i
started off as an account as an account
man but actually i moved into new
business a new business it just gives me
a thrill it always has because you're
meeting new businesses you're learning
about those businesses you're meeting
new people
there's the pitch i love the thrill of
the pitch the chase and all of that and
so it constantly felt like it was a new
job and especially because i had three
maternity leaves during that period as
well
i grew as a person each time i had my
babies
people often don't think that but you
learn new things about yourself and so i
came back each time refreshed and
excited but as i said by the end after
the uh after the 12th year it was like
no this was time time to do something
new
and kamarama the agency where you were
the fourth partner and the owner um
at some point in that journey you get a
call from you get head hunted
by meta
well
facebook because yeah at the time
facebook so it's 2013
and
you know the agency is going brilliantly
and i am also the president of the
institute of practitioners in
advertising it's the trade body for the
ad industry and i'm the first woman in
its almost hundred year history to take
on that role
and my whole mission was about
making the uk the most digital minded
digital first
country because i could see that the
opportunities there for the industry
were going to be huge if we could
capitalize on what was happening in
silicon valley
and so yes i did get a call carolyn
everson came it was another cup of
coffee which she actually said would you
like breakfast so i go for breakfast and
we'd met through an awards thing a year
or so earlier
and it's very american i'll never forget
we're in the ivy i'm surrounded by
literally everybody i know
and she literally comes straight out
i've got my water i'm drinking my water
and she goes nicola i'm here to see if
you're interested in heading up a mia
for facebook and i literally splurted
water out
and i said oh no no i i don't think so
why what are you talking about and she
goes oh
i and she said oh um well people have
suggested your name and i've been
looking for a while and i said well i've
got kamarama and it's going great and i
said i'll tell you what let me think
about it so i went home that night and i
spoke to my husband john he goes are you
nuts
he said and it put it in context it was
just after facebook had floated hadn't
been going so well i was a huge fan of
facebook though but i felt a deep
connection to all the people that we'd
hired at kamarama you know 250 people
that relied on us for their mortgages
and were part of the vision and the
dream there
but i gave it the overnight and i woke
up in the morning and i thought
actually
this one's now got my you know i'm
excited about this i i can start to
imagine
what that could do
because i'd always loved tech i'd always
been interested in it
and this would give me a ringside view
so
i said all right i'm interested and then
fast forward we had a whole recruitment
process and ultimately got the job i've
got to be honest that doesn't sound
that um breakfast at the ivy doesn't
sound like the most well thought through
pitch
[Laughter]
yeah that's that's how it was she should
maybe smooth schmooze you a little bit
first and yeah it was direct it was
directed
yeah i quite like that as well i have to
say
and and that that prospect of becoming
the head of e-m-e-a is that's terrifying
that that would be
terrifying for anyone the prospect
facebook is this huge company it's
hugely socially significant it's now
public company the prospective of
leading so many regions
terrifying you know most people would
would be overcome with imposter syndrome
probably
i it's not how i saw it i just saw it as
a huge opportunity i loved the products
i mean so it started with something that
i absolutely passionately believed in
i was a huge fan of mark zuckerberg and
sheryl sandberg
um
before i had the job and so to have the
privilege of to work for two of the
finest leaders that have ever worked in
business ever
um and to work so closely was
was just an extraordinary opportunity
and
you know it was so early on i mean i
remember you know we we hadn't opened a
lot of the offices back then london only
had a couple of hundred people
working there and so it was really early
it was really scrappy i'm good in that
i'm i'm good in kind of bringing people
together setting out what the objectives
are working towards what the vision
should be and i knew the industry okay
this was my industry these were all the
things that i loved working with some of
the best and the most
smartest of people but when you start
that job it's a public company it's as i
said hugely socially significant
is there any element of what the [ __ ] am
i doing here oh yeah of course
completely and
you know joining
you know i thought i knew digital before
i i started and then i really got to
understand
and those first few months and i think
this is true for anybody that that comes
and joins meta you literally feel like
you're drinking from the fire hose
you've got information coming at you
left right and center you've got to make
decisions quick quick quick on the
decisions and i find that quite
exhilarating and i'm a great writer i
write things down i'm learning i'm
processing in terms of that's how i
retain knowledge
and it just felt energizing i hadn't
felt like that since some of the very
early days in my career and i still feel
like that today i have to be honest
when you think about taking on a new
role um
in your career is there some kind of
framework or principles or
characteristics you're looking for when
you're making that decision we i get
asked this a lot when i meet people that
listen to this podcast or when they dm
about they're at that kind of crossroads
where they're trying to weigh up one of
two options what advice would you give
so i
definitely always
research the business which is obviously
what you would do but then i'm very into
also understanding it better by having
lots of cups of coffee with people that
are in and around the business and it's
it's a two-way thing especially at a
senior level where they're interviewing
me but i'm also interviewing them and
i've got my list of questions and you
know really wanting to understand what
what's motivating what they're looking
for is it what i'm looking for as well
and squaring that
and then writing lists you know the pros
and the cons of why this may or may not
be a good thing and picking up also the
challenges that people have as well so
that you're very clear going in what are
the things that need to be fixed what
are the things that shouldn't be fixed
that are working really well and where
some of the other opportunities are and
then i often go back after a few months
into them and just reflect on what i've
written
uh and see what i've done as a result
and how much does the
family play a role in that decision you
spoke about going and speaking to john
about it
huge i was huge i mean up until this
point i'd largely been uk based i did
europe as well but i'd largely been uk
based i didn't travel a lot john
traveled more
um you know we've got four kids and so
it was very clear to me that if i was
gonna take on this role that it was
gonna mean a lot of travel
and how did i feel i'd also been working
four days a week up until this point
and because that was something i had
done when gabby my our eldest was one i
just didn't feel that i was getting um
being good at anything
and so
that was something that i'd taken on so
it was going to be a really big change
and john and i really sat and talked
about it and he went just go for it he
said this off but he said i'll i'll root
myself more at home so that you can go
and do those things and we made a kind
of thing between ourselves that i'd
always make sure wherever i was in the
world i'd come home for the weekend and
we'd always have the sabbath together
we'd always be there as a family
together but in the week i would travel
so yeah it was um it wasn't just my
decision it was it was a joint decision
i i couldn't have done it unless i'd had
his his full support
on that point of working four days a
week when gabby was was born um what was
behind that decision give me some color
there i felt that
i wasn't being a good wife i didn't feel
i was being a good mum a good kind of
family member good friend just work was
all consuming and i needed just a bit
more time to be able to do the things
that i also that were also important in
my life you get one go at this thing
and so
i worked out that actually i probably
just needed the friday if i had a friday
that i could do the things that i wanted
to do and remember this is pre-tech all
this stuff we didn't have tech at all
our fingertips and everything and so i i
went to talk to my bosses and they're
actually incredibly open about it they
cut my salary by 20
of course but they got me for i did the
same job in essence but did it in four
days through the discipline that i
applied
um and so that's that's where it came
from and honestly it was one of the very
best things that i ever did it did mean
that i took some changes in my career
though i think back now and i didn't
push myself to do a ceo job when i was
in was was in agency life because i felt
that i probably needed to be there five
days in order to do that but i have no
regrets about that because the
experiences that i did as a result of
having that time i think you know
fulfilled me and also make made me who i
am
there's a huge importance for and
you know when i when you said that i was
just thinking about how how self-aware
it is to really tune in to what matters
for you because it's so easy and
tempting sometimes to just
um try and take on more and try and get
the highest
sounding status job you possibly can to
be a ceo even if it's and i i think
about this a lot of my career that
sometimes i just maybe need to pause and
think about what how i feel and what
really really matters to me as opposed
to just being dragged by what i think
i'm supposed to do right yeah i think
that's i think that's true for a lot of
people
i
and i think it's we often don't put the
discipline into our personal lives that
we do in our work lives and often our
work lives are dictated by others here's
the path that you'll climb up
off you go
and actually just stopping and going
what matters to me in my whole life
and i was always really clear my
nostalgia was always my family i would
john and i always wanted to have a big
family four kids
that was really important to to be
around for them as well
i love the fact that like oh you know
our kids are older now and they choose
to hang with us is a real source of
pride and joy for us both
so
being as intentional on the personal
side as as on the work side these things
aren't mutually exclusive you might have
to trade things at different times but
if ultimately the person feels more
fulfilled and happy then surely that's a
good thing right it's very rare for
people to turn down a promotion
which is an interesting concept i
actually remember the day where i
offered our
marketing director
the chance of our head of marketing the
chance to be the marketing director of
the whole company and i remember them
saying no no thanks
you know as a ceo you take that one of
two ways you think you know
is this is and this is just being
completely honest is this not an
ambitious person do they not like it
here you know but when i when i spoke to
this individual to find out the
reasoning behind their decision i just
had the most amount of respect for them
i respected them so much more because of
that self-awareness to know that they in
that personal life they wanted something
a little bit different and also they
they the person communicated to me that
he didn't feel like he was quite there
yet
and it was just i will never forget that
day because it only ever happened once
and we employed you know more than a
thousand people over the last 10 years
so
um it's just and i don't think it's a
conversation people have enough which is
like
you don't have to accept the next rung
on the ladder just because it's the next
wrong on the ladder and yeah i agree
with that and actually it's something
we've already gone deep in that meta
because what that often means is you
take somebody from doing a job they're
brilliant at and they love and you put
them into a role often as a people
manager because people manager means
success right
where
they they're not as good and so it
doesn't work for anybody then and so we
actually have something which is an
individual contributor where you can
rise up as an individual contributor be
very very senior
but not have to manage loads of people
because that's a totally different and
i'd never heard of that before i thought
i i think it's really a fantastic
concept for keeping and motivating great
talent
it is because much of the reason why
people love their work is because of the
relationship they have with their peers
and when you move them to management
roles those relationships are somewhat
changed yeah often broken so
makes a lot of sense um you get
three years into your career at facebook
and then um you get some awful news
yeah um
so i am
45 then
in november 2016
and living this amazing life right i'm
flying around the kids are thriving
family's great
and
i'm busy and feeling great and i i had
um
had this little lump in my in my groin
tiny like the size of a pee
and honestly wouldn't have thought
anything of it but i have a a really
good girlfriend who is um who's a doctor
and i just mentioned it to her literally
in passing like i wouldn't have gone and
seen a doctor for it
and she has probably nothing if it's
still there
let me know in a few weeks
and it it was so i went to see her
and she she put her hands on me and i
saw in her eyes
um that she
that she wasn't happy about it and i
said what is it she goes i don't know
but you need to see someone i don't know
what it is
and
she sent me um sent me to a doctor who
was turned out to be the wrong doctor
but it was he was a gynecologist
and he said um
he said you're fine you examine me he
goes but i literally had my coat on he
goes but you know what while you're here
he said we should just do a ct scan
i thought okay i was by myself because i
really didn't think it was anything so i
went and had a ct scan which is quite an
intrusive thing if you're not kind of
expecting it
invasive
and
and then i went home didn't think
anything of it
it was a friday
and
got home and put my phone away because i
was busy doing other things
and then i remember i picked up my phone
and there were so many missed calls
from my friend the doctor and also from
this 0207 number
um which i didn't recognize
and
i can still remember the feeling of just
being physically sick
and i went up to see john and i said to
john i think this is going to be very
bad news i'm going to phone lisa while
she's my gp friend while you're with me
and she just said have you spoken to the
doctor i said no she said i'm coming
over
honestly she lives around the corner it
was the longest five minutes of anyone
getting to me
and she told me um
that the scan had shown that i had
tumors
everywhere all over my chest all
underarms everywhere
and they didn't know what it was
and that um
that began the process over the worst
weekend of our lives
um googling everything trying to work it
out because you can't see comfort see
doctors at the weekend nobody's around
had to wait till monday morning
had a whole fiasco of
going to meet a surgeon trying to take
her one of the tumors out but they
wouldn't take it out because they didn't
know which was the one to take out and
it was just very frustrating and
being a person that's very used to
like you you're like knowing what you
want to do getting in control making
things happen like you just couldn't do
anything
you had to wait till monday morning
to
go for a pet scan
to understand it and then over it was
just all just so much information and
also we didn't want the children to know
because we didn't know what it was and
so it was just john and i
sort of isolated
working through all of this
but within a few days it was
i got the diagnosis that i had
something called follicular lymphoma
which is an incurable blood cancer
most people that have this it can take
two to three years to get diagnosed i
got diagnosed in five days
and
it was
it was a shock it was
i'm thinking about it now and i still
can't believe what i'm telling you that
this is something that happened to me
um and is happening to me yeah
how does how does how does the world you
look out upon
look differently through that period of
your life that weekend
because you've gone from flying around
the world you know thinking about a
particular professional challenge and
life is normal and then
boom
i did a lot of crying i cried so much i
mean
it was a physical thing i just remember
it being very physical the feeling
i couldn't sleep i actually lost half a
stone in one weekend
um
and then i just remember thinking on
that monday morning
that that's not me i mean i
catastrophized everything because of
course when you heard the word cancer
and tumors cancer we knew it was bad
before we knew what it actually was
i went to all the worst places in my
mind as to what was going to happen
fast forward i was going to have chemo
then it wasn't going to work then i was
going to die then you know the children
would be left alone it was just horrific
absolutely horrific the games your mind
can play on you or that you allow to
play on yourself
and i remember thinking on that monday
morning
i actually did my hair did my makeup and
said i'm going to face this in the way
that i face everything i'm going to take
it one day at a time
and you know whatever the cards i'm
dealt with i'm going to make sure i live
the most
with what i have
and i'm never ever going to allow myself
to go back to that weekend that i just
had which was just horrific and i didn't
and so i took it on
you know understood what i had and then
had to
start to process that and then start to
tell people because you're right on that
monday i was supposed to be flying to
china
and so i couldn't do that
and so i had to tell my bosses that i
wasn't going to be able to tell them
you know the reason why or what i knew
at that point
and you know i will always be
unbelievably grateful to
sheryl sandberg for
literally just saying we're here for you
whatever you need
um
we've got your back
and that was you know for your boss to
tell you that is
you know the most important thing in the
world i'll never forget that
that conversation with your kids
worst conversation of our lives um
we
gathered that it was about it was a week
later and it was deliberately a week
later because
danny our on number two was just 18 that
weekend and he'd had a big party on the
saturday night
so we didn't want it to spoil it for him
and
so we gathered the kids on the sunday
morning um
all sat round the table
to try and tell them and i actually
i couldn't i just couldn't get the words
out
it was horrific
you know in in a moment you change your
kids you you know they've got this life
and in that moment you bring a different
dimension into their lives
john had to um
he had to tell them i couldn't get the
words out
zach was 11 at the time
he's our youngest and
you know he just he
he asked me for you know if i was gonna
die
finish me off
finish me off
how does how does someone respond to
that it took me back to
a conversation i had with my mum when my
mum found a lump in her breast when i
was younger
and
and it was the first thing i thought i
must have been about eleven
must have been about eleven when i got
that phone call
how does how do how does a parent deal
with that conversation with an eleven
year old when they ask that question
there's no right or wrong is there on
these things what i what i said to him
was i hope not
gonna try my best
and
what i promised them that day was that
they could always ask me anything
there was never a question that they
couldn't ask and that we would fight it
as a family together and we would
learn about it together
and it wasn't a secret and there was no
shame
sometimes there's a shame with these
things
especially
it was particularly difficult because
nobody had ever heard of this cancer
and
and the fact that it was incurable so
all that language with cancer that we
knew
of we're going to beat it and cut it out
and do those things
couldn't say those things
it was this was going to be a journey
and this was now going to be a part of
our lives
and
yeah i think probably
probably changes it all a little bit
that day
the word incurable is a is a hard word
to accept especially when you're
you have the type of personality that i
can tell you have
it almost seems like control is when i
hear that word it's like the control is
taken from me because if you know my
natural um when i was reading about your
initial response to receiving that
diagnosis that cut out attack it was
gonna that would be my response
yeah it was i mean that was part of that
weekend where i was just trying to find
a surgeon i kind of felt if i found that
surgeon and they cut it out then that
would be on the path to curing it
because in that moment they didn't know
if it was a they thought it might have
been a breast cancer that had spread so
they were going at it that way but
actually it turned out it was a lymphoma
that happened to be around the lymph
nodes in in the underarms so
um
it was a whole new language and vocab is
to try and understand what it means to
have an incurable cancer
and then
to start to understand that this one
didn't have much research and so all the
questions you want to ask it's okay so
if i have treatment how long is that
going to last for and how long will i be
clear for and you go into a remission
and then it comes back and
that there's just no knowledge and no
information
in the way that you want to have that
knowledge and so
i think i think one of the challenges of
that word incurable is that it's always
with you
and there's not a day that i goes by
where i don't think about the fact that
i do have a blood cancer
um
and that the risks especially through
the last two years that we've had with
covid
have been very challenging for me in the
family
up until the point where better
treatments were available for people
like me
in these moments both professionally and
personally there's uh
um
there's sometimes a desire to be
strong on the outside
brave face
yes and
no
i was very
lucky
i didn't i never made this a secret and
and in many ways i couldn't have
suddenly disappeared from work because
people knew i was having tests
and so i i told
i told my team straight away
and and people are wonderful you know
people like we're here for you what can
we do what do you need
i was like i don't know
at the moment
and this cancer
as i said is quite different in as much
as i didn't even have treatment for 18
months because
what what is understood is the fact that
because there's we can't cure it
and because there could be new
treatments
then the doctors do this thing called
watch and wait where literally they
watch and they wait and they they see
what's happening or as patients call it
watch and worry
and you have scans and you have blood
tests and then there'll come a point
maybe
that you'll need treatment and my point
came
18 months after that first diagnosis
where i was just unlucky that it grew
around my kidney area some people can go
several years without needing treatment
but they said i could have it would it
would give me kidney failure and so
they deemed that i should i should get
the treatment there that was a blow and
the only reason that was a blow that
moment was because i thought i was going
to get two years that's a kind of the
average after if you get an early
diagnosis and i got 18 months so
that was a blow um and then i had six
months of chemotherapy and 18 months of
immunotherapy treatment as well and it
was you know i i did well not everyone
does as well as me it it put the cancer
into a form of remission they call it no
evidence of disease
but you know
no chemo is fun that's for sure
what kind did you get any psychological
support throughout this process because
we talk a lot about the physical
symptoms but the
the mental um
the mental difficulties i mean
are just
quite honestly like
unimaginable i just all of the words
you've used and the context of the
family and
all of these things your team members
was there some kind of psychological
support that you sought out in therapy
or other
actually there wasn't but i also think
it was because i was so open
you know you talked about did i put on a
brave face i think the hardest thing i
did was when i told my story more
publicly
and i did it in two parts the first part
was when i stood up we used to do an
end-of-year conference in emea where
everybody flew in
and i stood and told my story to
everybody and that was one of the
hardest things i've done with the story
of the diagnosis
and i i wept on the stage i mean i
literally had tears coming um down my
eyes as i did it in front of everybody
that worked with me
and
people just inundated with me with hugs
and you know that thing of don't hug me
when i'm crying it's gonna make me cry
more
that that happened but people were so so
supportive
and then again when i when i told my
story on world cancer day um
in the february
i was just inundated with support and
love from people people i didn't even
know
and so many people sharing the story of
having a similar disease or incurable
disease that they've not gone public on
for a variety of reasons
whether it was fear of
it was largely to do with work actually
largely to do with they won't get that
promotion if people think they're weak
physically
and so they live with this extra burden
of having an inc a disease and putting
on a brave face
hiding doctor's appointments i never had
to do any of that and so
i felt strong mentally the whole way
through this
i got my head around the cards
that have been dealt with to me and as i
said i was never going to go back to
that weekend and so i made sure that i
protected myself through the things that
i did through the things that i could
take control on
um in in order to get that but i know
that's not true for everyone and i
certainly know
that through one of the things that we
did was to grow this group on facebook
called living with follicular lymphoma
it's almost 10 000 people now which i
kind of pinch myself because it's it's
the largest gathering of people that
have ever existed with follicular
lymphoma and could only have happened
because of facebook
but the mental challenge and the anguish
that people in the group talk about
every single day
that haunts me and and that sort of
drives me to do the work that i do in
terms of trying to find a cure it haunts
you yeah because people
i know how blessed i am i'm blessed with
my with the job that i have with my
family with my faith with my community
all those pillars that support me and
and make me who i am
and i know how lucky i am to have that
and
[Music]
i read every day that so many are not
the group acts as a support for them
because
you don't want to talk to somebody else
that's got a different cancer it's not
helpful
you know
i had that in the early days a lot of
people with breast cancer wanted to tell
me their story and it's actually
thank you but it's not that helpful i
need to know people that are
two years ahead of me on this journey
who've got follicular lymphoma that i
had the treatments i had will have
that that's the best help and support
possible
was there ever a decision you made about
whether to
continue with work because
this is i know this is a question you've
kind of been asked before about whether
you you know some would assume that if
if they were to get that diagnosis they
might retract from work
and and just stay home
what was your thinking around that
it honestly never occurred to me and
i think i'd been very intentional in my
life about the things that mattered to
me in the things that i wanted i love
what i do i absolutely love my job it is
a lot of who i am
it is something that gives me huge
energy good and you know helps me on my
own journey in learning so it never
occurred to me that if i was well enough
um that i that i would carry on working
and work out you know i was asked you
know take the time off whatever you need
to do i was like oh no no i don't want
any time off i want to do i want to keep
things as normal as possible because i i
feel pretty blessed with the with the
life that i have and if i'm well i'll i
want to do the job and i thank god i
have been well and even through the
chemotherapy i was able to work which is
can often be a surprise because there's
different types of chemotherapy and
thankfully the one i had is not didn't
react as severely to me as some people
have with theirs i didn't lose my hair
for example
which i know is a hugely traumatic thing
especially for women and so
i was able to work but to do it in
different ways
on that day when you get that message
from the doctors that um
there's no evidence of disease
and that you're
follicular
lymphoma
is in
remission yeah how is that day how do
you do you remember the day i do and
honestly it was a bit of an anti-climax
because it only meant for now and so i
sort of
i'd gone into that meeting going
either way manage your own expectations
so you're not disappointed
and so if i didn't build myself up to go
it's going to be good it's going to be
good news i was like it's this is just
going to be what it will be and you'll
deal with it and i think that really
helped in terms of the management of the
expectation and so when he told me that
i was like that's good and he goes well
aren't you more happy i was like no that
that is good news but there's still a
journey ahead and you know i want to
find i want to be
part of the team that finds a cure for
this thing so that other people don't
have to go through these meetings like
you and i are going to have to have
must be a nice conversation to have you
with your kids though it was good news
um
you'd sort of get halfway through
they've done a scan to say it was going
well
and so they sort of drip fed that
information and but i didn't allow
myself that euphoria of yay i didn't do
that moment i i
and that is quite a weird thing if i
think back on it now because
of the nature of the person that i am i
am quite celebratory i am kind of
that person but i that one was a more
muted
certainly was more muted to me it
doesn't entirely surprise me that was
your reaction because you talked about
um it being a process of like
expectation management and one would
assume that if you can control your
response to
good news it also helps you control your
response to bad news in the same way it
seems
to me i've done that in the past as
almost a defense mechanism yeah it is
it's a protection it definitely is a
protection thing because if i was going
in there going i hope it's good news i
hope it's good news and it's not i'm
just going to be flawed right
and so i already knew what the worst
thing could be i i've got an incurable
blood cancer that's not going away
but it would just be
you know let's see where this next part
of this journey takes me
how did that news impact the way that
you saw your life and uh because
for me the pandemic and watching what
happened happened to the world and
seeing how that there was this tectonic
plate underneath all of us that i'd
never realized called our health
that i as a young person had never even
realized could was there or could move
and that if it did move in fact my whole
life sat upon it my career my
relationships my family everything my
goals my ambitions my future was all sat
on this thing called health and one day
it shakes and you didn't know it was
there
how does that change your view of your
life and the decisions you make
yeah and in many ways our family had a
trial run on the pandemic because going
through chemo you have to be super
careful i mean we had the masks and the
sanitizer at the door back in 2018 for
anyone that came into the house i didn't
go to the theater i didn't go out didn't
go on planes etc
so i had to be super super careful
because my immune system was shot to
pieces
but actually
i didn't make a lot of major changes you
know a lot of people that get a
diagnosis like this do look their life
in in that moment and go well
getting divorced
spending all that off to vegas i i
didn't do any of those things because
i think i'd been very intentional about
the about the life
that i have
and been very
purposeful about some of the choices
that you know we've made together as a
family and so
no i there was none of those kind of
crazy things
did it change how you allocate your time
at all did it yes i did um so i took
control of some of the things i could
control and so there was enough evidence
knocking around about lifestyles and
diets and things like that especially
with the disease which is about the
immune system about reducing
inflammation within the body and so i
had a shocking diet i was really not
very good at exercise i.e i did none
whatsoever and so i did build that into
my life so yeah they were i guess some
pretty big changes then that i did make
you talk about being intentional
about your life what does that mean to
you and why is that important yeah i
i actually practice something called
vision writing which is um
you write as though it's a year from now
and you set out looking back on the year
you've just had what you're going to
achieve
and all the research says if you write
stuff down then you and you share it
with people you're more likely to do it
and i do it around my personal life i do
it around work and then i do it around
community
and
i take people on the journey with me you
know to help to work out what it's gonna
write it down and then i then i share it
and that's really helped me to be really
thoughtful about what i want to do in
the next year and certainly with the
family it's involved a huge amount of
travel we absolutely love traveling and
seeing different places and exploring
and it's we sit together and we kind of
go what do you want to do this year what
are the things and when the kids were
smaller
you know that some of the things that
they wanted to do were kind of little
things i remember there was one where um
i think sam just wanted to go and have a
chinese meal i'm like yep we'll have a
chinese meal
and his brothers and sisters laughing at
him for going you know
you underplayed that one yeah you
couldn't ask anything from what you are
doing you know different personalities
of the children coming through but i
think i think
that that has made a difference
i read about some advice that sheryl
sandberg had given you around that time
um about
not
uh engaging in secondary worrying
yeah
what is that well that the secondary
worrying is what i was talking about
which is well i'm going to have chemo
it's not going to work
i'm going to die
john's going to marry a wicked woman
children are going to be miserable boom
i'm exhausted and it's miserable and
depressing and
that that's just
giving the power away and and she was
right i mean it was such good advice
just to kind of
to say that don't don't allow yourself
to do that and i think
you know i think that is something that
people do with bad news you know you
take yourself into a into a different
place of all the things that that could
go wrong but i think people do that in
in all aspects of life if you go for a
job interview and you know you start to
worry about not getting it well that's
not going to be very helpful is it in
terms of how you're going to present
yourself
so yeah
because you're right impacts performance
but also that mental
torture yeah
which you're choosing you know to
inflict upon yourself just makes the
whole process miserable doesn't it yeah
and we will do that oh yeah
it's easier said than done
but there's i often you know people ask
me about um advice for like moments of
chaos the only advice i've ever been
able to conjure really is
um trying to plant yourself as much as
you possibly can in the present moment
and and that which you can control yeah
totally i'm absolutely i i heard a great
um
speech years ago from a guy who'd
climbed everest who basically said you
don't climb everest you get to base camp
one and that's your thing and then you
work out how you get to two and you
never climb everest you go from point to
point and certainly in chaotic moments
it's like what are the things you can
control and what are your small
milestones that you need to get to in
order to either get out of the chaos or
to hit the the north star do you see
that in great leaders within within
facebook slash mata oh yeah definitely i
mean you know having you know mark
zuckerberg pivoting the whole company as
he as he did last year
um changing the name of the company and
going this is what we've done for the
last 17 years here's where the new thing
is going to be
this is where we're going to go that's
bold that's extraordinary so few leaders
do something like that i mean it's one
of the reasons that i love what i do is
get to learn and be inspired by him
what's he like
he's incredible absolutely incredible
leader
he sees things
that others don't necessarily see
and he's always right
in those things in terms of what he
plants in terms of where the north stars
are no question and then he's really
clear he gives very clear
direction as to what's important what
what matters where the trade-offs are
going to be
and what he expects of people and i
think having that clarity
of you know
the things that we're going to measure
the company against or the individual
against
those are really important things and
you know growing up in agencies as we
both did those were things that didn't
really exist it was all done on
touchy-feely how's that person doing
and if you weren't
you know if you weren't kind of in that
crowd then it was hard for people
whereas working matter you've got really
clear objectives as to what you need and
should do and the fact that everybody
has them
means that we can point towards the
north star and in this case the building
our part in the building of the
metaverse
when you talk about he you know he has
this very high conviction and he can see
things that a lot of people can't see um
and then it's proven right what are the
key
moments of sort of self-disruption where
you think he was really right right he
was exceptionally high conviction to the
point that it probably didn't make sense
to a lot of people
but it but it was uh proven to be
correct it was mobile the first yeah it
was i think mobile is the first time
that we that strength of leadership and
that pivot
really came through and in the actions
that he had because
lots of leaders talk stuff but then
don't follow through with the action and
the fact that you know back in 2012 2013
mark turned around and said you know
facebook was was built late so it was
built on on desktop it wasn't mobile
first we need to shift the company to
mobile and so the product guys were
still coming in with desktop
innovations and he stopped them and you
know for two weeks he didn't have any
meetings because nobody had any mobile
applications to share with him of how
this was going to work and so by
being really clear as to what the
expectations were
people were able to move very quickly in
terms of what the deliverables and we've
seen it time and time again since then
so you know the the shift of video the
shift to stories and now the shift to
reels that we're going through the short
form video now is another one of these
pivotal moments that we that we've seen
in big companies it's hard to get i mean
you know
it's hard to get that agility and
innovation often to keep up with a
changing world for many reasons i mean
people have come to work they're
qualified in one thing they've done it
their whole life
so it's it's understandable why there
might be friction and reluctancy to go
from being like a you know a developer
on uh desktop to mobile like that's not
what i do i don't know it so
there's so much friction and resistance
how does how does mark in facebook and
how does the company overcome that you
talked about being very very clear what
does that mean in practical terms does
that mean like
you will be fired if you don't or does
it mean
no i think it's more about the culture
that's created that allows people to
fail
um and dem and talks about that with
openness and vulnerability if we try
this and it didn't work but if if we're
not setting ambitious goals then we then
we we wouldn't not be failing we have to
fail as a tech company to get to those
bigger north stars but the key thing is
is to make sure that we're taking the
learnings from those failures and then
applying it and telling the stories of
those things as well so you create a
safe environment for people to go well
i'm going to do this thing and i'm going
to go all in because this is my
hypothesis of why it will work and then
if it doesn't to have the
self-reflection to go why didn't what
can we learn what's the debriefing that
needs to happen and we take learnings
from so many different places you know
um the military is a great one that you
know when operations don't all
operations good and bad they debrief
directly after that's kind of a muscle
that we also have as well and that just
keeps making us better
on that on that switch from
web to mobile let's say um i'd read that
market basically said i'm not taking and
you kind of alluded to it a little bit
there but i'm not taking any meetings
until people start bringing me
mobile products to look at
is that is that true
yeah because that for me is one of those
that's a very practical thing where a
leader goes i'm so high conviction that
i'm no longer going to take meetings
about the old thing absolutely and
that's that for me is an example of of
what i was talking about like in a very
practical sense that's
that's a
very high conviction thing to do
absolutely and a different example of it
is um
on the shift to live video
when that was first becoming a thing
mark called what we call a lockdown and
moved resources on the engineering side
from whatever they had been working on
and it's not like those things weren't
important that they were working on to
be able to then work on
this product
so convinced was he of it and when we go
into lockdown it's kind of it's like
hackathons it's day and night people are
kind of going for it and it's you know
you set a clear time period with the
deliverables and uh and the expectation
when the deliverables happen and when
mark might present
his vision for these sort of tectonic
shifts that are going on in the macro
tech environment that he believes are
important to facebook how does he
communicate that to everybody to bring
them along yeah because often leaders
when they when they have a vision in
their mind they'll just go we're going
to do this but i think bringing people
along is is a process of
explaining and inspiring
yeah it is and
you know he does a weekly q a for the
whole company where the company can ask
anything and it's interesting because
you know we're learning as a company as
well we're 17 years old some of the
questions get repeated week in week out
because you've got new people coming and
so now we answer some of those by um by
writing about it but he's very open
about it and he talks about what we're
learning he brings in other leaders to
share how they're doing on some of the
the challenges we have you know after
every earnings is you know a company uh
meeting where we're setting out the
vision as to where we see the next year
so everyone's really clear about what
the north star are what the priority
areas for the company are
and what everybody can do to contribute
their part to each one of those company
priorities
so this meta shift
i think it was very
surprising to a lot of people because
it's one thing to you know add a add a
new
i don't know product to a company but to
change the name
is a very high conviction statement
about the future i mean it doesn't get
more high conviction than that
can you tell me about when you first
heard that
facebook was changing into meta your
initial thoughts about that and how it
was delivered to the company
yeah so
i found out earlier i was one of the
team that obviously found out a bit
earlier
and i just remember just going oh my god
i absolutely love this and it basically
picks up on a lot of what we've just
talked about i love the boldness i love
the name absolutely love the name
i saw that it addressed pretty quickly
you know some of the challenges that we
saw about the fact that as i said the
company's 17 years old and started just
as facebook
and we had facebook as the company and
we had facebook as the biggest app
but by now we were all these other apps
as well
instagram whatsapp you know portal
oculus quest etc messenger and there was
a lot of confusion around it so i
thought not only did it solve that but
then to show us a kind of a new north
star
for the company we'd always been a
social technology company and this is
kind of a new way of how people are
going to
communicate
live experience in a whole new way going
forwards and we're right at the
beginning of it right at the beginning
when you first hear that though is it
not slightly terrifying no it's so
totally exciting and
because we're now in a really
interesting period which is we're old
enough to have seen what you know the
first iterations the first couple of
iterations of what the internet were and
we're now at the beginning of this third
phase the metaverse web 3 all of this
coming together that wouldn't have been
possible before because the technology
wasn't there and a lot of the technology
still isn't there we're talking about
something that's still going to be
probably five to ten years off before
that really immersive experience for
many uh is realized
and so to be right in at the early doors
i just think is
super super exciting and to be one of
the companies that will hopefully help
to shape that
what is the metaverse
it's funny
it's funny because it always almost
reminds me of like early you know early
web one and web two people ask the same
questions over and over again and i've
watched the like news anchors saying
what is internet anyway and then
stumbling to answer the question and i
see this a lot we're all struggling in
some respects to find a nice definition
but in facebook's definition what is
what is the meta bus yeah so it's the
next iteration of the internet one that
is much more immersive
one that can
allow you to do things that you couldn't
do um perhaps in real life
um or enhance that
and it's going to be a continuum of
things it's not going to just be one
thing people often think it takes you
straight to this vr immersion but
actually it's a continuum of everything
from how you use your phone you know it
uses ar vr uses ai
um
and it's gonna in the same way that you
know that web two has impacted so many
different aspects of our lives so this
will too um as well
i know you must be so i'm gonna i'm
gonna make a presumption i know you must
be sick of of the questions around the
negative consequences like with web 2 we
i think
we conducted an experiment about social
media and social networking because the
technology enabled us to so we had these
you know initially we had desktop
computers then we had mobile devices the
internet got really good
these social networks emerged from
friendster to bebo to myspace to
facebook and all of that
and in hindsight we've now learned about
the role that these tools play for
better and for worse in our lives
because of this new web 3 metaverse
technology being perceived as being some
kind of like headset you'll don and
you'll go into this other
planet where you'll be
doing much of your social interactions
that you do in real life now in this
virtual world
people are understandably scared
they're scared because they're already
seeing their kids glued to social media
apps and tick tock and instagram and
messenger and snapchat or whatever and
they're thinking well they're going to
be wearing a headset and you know some
virtual on some virtual planet
you're a parent
is there not and i know that you you
care a lot about your own kids screen
times because you've said that before
it's one of the things that you're very
particular on especially with the
youngest of your children
um
do you have any concerns that we're
going more and more into a digital
world that's taking away the
what it is to be a human
so we're already in a digital world and
so that that's a fact and that's a
reality and how we live within that i
think is the important question
and our vision of the metaverse isn't
one where we're gonna increase it just
it's more about that the time that you
spend online can be so much more
enhanced but to be clear there is
nothing better than sitting with you in
your dining room right now
that's fabulous right the fact we can
have a hug and all the rest of it those
things are great i never want to
replicate that but if you have got the
ability to be able to to step into
another world to see things that perhaps
most people would never be fortunate
enough to see you know the barrier reef
match your picture wherever those things
are that's pretty extraordinary how we
educate in the future you can't change
what's going to happen when it comes to
technology and progress
but i think there is another aspect that
i think that we've learned from what's
happened in the last 20 years which is
that technology can be used for good and
bad
and so let's get ahead now early doors
before this thing is fully realized
let's create guard rails which is
something that we as a company are doing
we're putting money out there working
with academia working with governments
etc to start to work out what the guard
rails should be so it doesn't come as a
surprise
um that is actually something that we
can build for intentionally from the
get-go it's a huge opportunity as well
isn't it for
for society it's a huge opportunity for
entrepreneurs
for for um the builders of the future
it's a huge opportunity for brands yeah
this is just so exciting because it is
going to impact everything i think about
the fact that you know my grandchildren
will will finally learn in a different
way than i learnt at school and the fact
that they will be able to have an
immersive history lesson or immersive
geography lesson where they can actually
go for a you know a scuba dive swim and
and see what the coral reefs are like or
walk down the streets of ancient
jerusalem as it was then and have that
brought to life i mean that looking up
and looking around and and seeing what
that i mean totally going to disrupt
education in a positive exciting way but
already seeing how it's you know
impacting for good things like the the
the health industry
and medicine where we're seeing surgeons
now already training
um and doing operations in in vr and
practicing which
and the stats are saying that they're
coming out as better surgeons than
people that are just getting the odd
body that they can kind of experiment
and that kind of makes sense as well and
then from the business side when you
asked about brands the opportunity it's
going to create for creators and whole
new jobs that we can't even imagine yet
that don't that don't exist i think the
crater economy is going to be something
that we're going to see a really
significant
uptick in more people being able to make
money through creativity i think that's
really exciting i get all the excitement
we what we learned from the last 20
years of the internet is that there's
always a cost
there's always a cost when you're
thinking about what those what the the
downsides are what are what what are the
things you're guarding against like what
are the things you're thinking okay we
need to make sure that we build with
this in mind because i don't think we
did that over the last 20 years with the
internet
um
i don't think we built very
intentionally
over the last 20 years so
yeah i think i think it's an important
question i think about the fact that
we're being very intentional with
building diversity and equity into all
of our products and everything that we
do so
i am unbelievably proud of the fact that
you go in today and you want to create
your avatar and there's over a
quintillion different versions of
avatars that you can create
i don't know if we would have had that
10 years ago the fact that you can have
that can see to be very intentional
about some of these things that people
can represent themselves as they want to
be represented i think is really
important you know normally you would
you know
years ago you would start with you know
it's a white man
and then you would go from there well
that's not very inviting
the emojis are the same you know yeah so
it's a journey right so those i think
those are some of the things another one
that we've been very intentional about
um is about protecting physical space
because you have the ability um in the
metaverse to feel the social presence i
mean that's one of the amazing things
about it that you genuinely feel like
you are in the presence of someone and
hanging out with them and so being very
clear and one of the things we've we've
built is a personal boundary space so
that people can't come into it it makes
you feel like you've got about four foot
around you and if they come too close to
you it kind of pushes them out that's
that's a pretty cool thing then of
course you get the the feedback that
people go well what if i want to hug
someone and i'm like oh we've just built
that product so you don't have to so
then you have to build different things
in as well because you take the feedback
but it's building those things early i
think makes a difference
and we know now we've got enough
information and data from the last 20
years to be to understand a lot of these
things um
mark zuckerberg has been a character
that has been um
the public perception of him has been
written by the media
often i'd say almost always
unfairly in my opinion
as someone that knows him what how does
that make you feel
because i'll be i'm just going to be
completely honest look
i know a lot of people won't have
sympathy for someone that's a
billionaire in that whatever but
i don't know how a human being deals
with
that amount of constant
constant
attack
i don't know how they do it i mean
keep priscilla right there and my kids
right there and not turn anything on
he is um
[Music]
he passionate believes in the vision the
mission
the ability for people around the world
to be able to connect together
for businesses small businesses the
smallest of businesses to be able to
have the same
abilities to reach customers as the
largest
businesses in the world always could do
and that sort of
evening out of things all over the world
he passionately believes in that he's
driven by that and then you know i think
about marcus as you said the husband the
dad the son
extraordinary human being and the fact
that you know his pleasure to give
virtually all of his money away to
charity to cure diseases i mean
i think it's pretty extraordinary to
have made some of those decisions
in the way that he has
um
i personally find him inspiring
i find him
courageous i find him
kind and caring
but most of all i find him inspirational
do you think he's misunderstood
i know him to be the man that i just
described him to be
and so i'll leave others to judge that
interesting
because i don't know i think he's
misunderstood
so
and
i think that's largely because
and i know this is super unpopular but i
just don't really care um i think i
think it's largely because having spent
10 years working in social media in the
internet building companies in the space
living and working in san francisco in
the valley
um
when i s what i see in reality in the
day-to-day work of my life then what i
see in the headlines there's a huge
disparity between the two you know i've
been critical of all social media
platforms for various reasons i've got
big concerns and one of the ones more
you know over the last couple of years
that i've been more engaged in is just
the psychological impact of
comparison and what that says about
ourselves and you know seeing this
person on instagram and making me feel
inferior about myself and my self-esteem
and what we do about that um what how do
you think about that as a parent and a
mother when you that particular issue of
like the social experiment of our
context now being a billion people as
opposed to just our little tribe
which it might have been one day when we
were
most
human on in africa
i think um
look i think for for
one of the things that we've done
and this is an area of course we take
unbelievably seriously we start with the
fact
we don't want children on the platform
unless they're over 13. i think that's
really important and we do a lot to take
kids off that are
that are younger than that and we can
pick that up through things like ai
etc
but it's also working through some of
the tools that we have for kids as well
i mean
we have parent hubs and i think it's
important that people know that these
are places that parents can go to get
the resources to understand how to have
the conversations with their children as
well
we have things we work very closely with
charities all over the world especially
when it comes to young people
we've created products that say things
like take a break
and that you can set time limits for
yourself and give yourself a nudge we've
got things like
if it looks like someone's going to
write something mean it gives you a
nudge and go you sure you want to write
that and so we're working with those
charities as i say and we're doing
constant research with with young people
as well to make sure that we're
understanding where people are today and
of course we're very clear on the fact
that we we want them to come on the
platform to connect with their friends
to connect with you know
the music and the sports and the things
that that they care about but also the
fact that we can provide the resources
for parents as well i think that's also
important do you think do you see a lot
of these challenges as trade-offs
as in in order to have in order for me
to be able to connect with my sister who
lives on the other side of the world
when she's in japan living there
um there are trade-offs of that because
i have to
on many of the social platforms i have
to expand my context to a point where i
am going to potentially start involving
in sort of negative comparisons about
myself but do you see what i mean in
order to have some of the wonderful
things i mean i guess this is this is
life in order to have some of the
wonderful things we seek as humans
there's always
some kind of trade-off we have to make
but i think it goes back to
you're in control of the things that you
follow you're in control of the the
people that you want to engage with on
there and you can be very choiceful
about that and so
you know i i look at my you know if i
think about my instagram or my facebook
it fills me with joy because they are my
friends and my family and some are all
over the world now and living in
different places given that i'm living
in a different place
and just to be able to have that
community and that sense of togetherness
is something i could never have had and
especially
through this last couple of years where
we physically couldn't see people
for so much of it i mean thank goodness
for portal quite frankly because that
became a regular thing in my family in
terms of how the grandparents could
connect with the kids couldn't you know
connect with the different children
where they were at different times that
was something that was really important
same with my parents my parents have a
portal and um buying them
an iphone and then being able to use
whatsapp
uh was completely changed our family
you've got a family group yes we have
all right so for one christmas what's it
called bartlett's right
one christmas i bought my dad an iphone
and
up until that point he
he didn't have facebook or anything so
him getting facebook was the first time
he started to connect with the kids
after they'd all gone to university
and then when i bought him an iphone
then i bought my mum and iphone the
following christmas
um that's when they really stayed in
touch and then they got a portal and
then that's when things really changed
and it it has had a huge impact on us
because my parents live you know several
hours away their kids live all around in
every corner of the world so that has
brought our family a lot closer
um and also there's been a big
conversation recently which is i've been
heavily inspired by to be involved in
which is about personalized advertising
being someone who now is on the
receiving end of a lot of business
pitches over the last two years
i've had i think the biggest single
issue that small businesses have said to
me
that is affecting their business i'll
say befall of the supply chain inflation
stuff has been the change to
um
the personalized advertising problem
products on facebook i
my personalized advertising um now works
is less effective
and harder to track
the
attribution and the return i'm getting
on on my spend and a lot of this is
because of changes that have happened to
ios
what's your what are you seeing what are
you hearing what is your take on that
yeah so
you're absolutely right the changes that
apple made in terms of what they allowed
to happen
really impacted small businesses
and that was something we were very
vocal about and something that we talked
about and it was almost as though there
was this thing that you couldn't have
personalized advertising and privacy you
absolutely can and it was almost as
though personalized advertising isn't a
good thing it's a fantastic thing you
know i think about
you know my own personal feeds the fact
that i get to discover
brands and businesses that i would never
have known about um
that's a really good thing because it's
good for the business because you're
finding the new customers it's good for
the customer because you're finding new
things as well and it's good for the
other people that never see those ads
because they never should see them
because they're not relevant to them um
i saw recently a uh i don't know you are
a dog lover aren't you i've got it of
course i am i knew you were so there's a
dog hotel that you can go to and dorset
now that's a great ad if you want to
send your dog to gonna have a kind of a
staycation
and go and get made up and it's run by a
wonderful woman who has foster children
as well and they are all working
together
running this business that advertises on
solely on facebook i believe
and the business has grown
extraordinarily that they now employ
seven more people as a result of it now
there is no point advertising that to a
cat lover or to somebody that doesn't
have a pet that's pointless
but it's that personalization that that
works and that's one of the things that
i think has been so fantastic um about
the meta platforms is that it has
allowed small businesses as well as
large but really significantly small
businesses to be able to reach customers
that perhaps might not have known about
those products not necessarily just in
the cities that they live in but
actually in other countries around the
world as well where people want those
products and we're constantly refining
you know and and improving the
attribution and the measurement that you
that you just talked about and we're
seeing some really good results
accordingly hill our sponsor here on the
table is a prime example of that tell us
about that steve i don't know what any
opportunity to but i have to say their
sponsors i'll get destroyed by the asa
but um
they they're a prime example of that
their business heavily um grew off of
personalized advertising finding people
that i really really care about being
you know having a nutritionally complete
diet and that we're looking for
let me just read off the back
we're looking for this kind of product
that is plant-based that is um gives you
your protein and all of those things and
they went from
being a uk startup to the fastest
growing e-commerce company
internationally according to the sunday
times um very much aided by personalized
advertising on social media and facebook
in particular
um and even they have seen the uh the
negative consequence of the changes that
have happened it's really really
startling because it's a one-sided
narrative i think in the in the
the press largely but when you when you
are someone like me who spent who is
pitched thousands of times a month by
small businesses and you ask them the
question what is the thing you're
struggling with now and it's the same
answer every time over the last two
years
that's when i realized that that there
was a problem here and that there was a
second narrative and a conversation we
needed to be having
i want to get some advice from you
about work
i know most people listening to this
will really be um
in all of you the career you've had and
and trying to take some actionable
um
more actionable advice from this
conversation as to as to how they can
have a similar career they how they can
be successful in whatever endeavor
they're pursuing when i was thinking
about some of the advice you've given
previously one of the points you'd said
is about really understanding your core
strength and your core skills
why does that matter and how does one do
that
and what does it mean to understand your
core skills and strengths i think it's
about
understanding what what you enjoy i
think it starts there and then whether
you're playing what you're intrinsically
good at in with those areas as well
because actually sometimes people are
good at things but don't enjoy it and so
ultimately that will not make you as
fulfilled or as happy
as you as you can be
often you're not the best judge of
yourself
and so finding people around you either
family and friends but actually also
work colleagues that can start to say
what is it about me that's good
what is it about me that maybe isn't so
good help me help me understand those
things better and then you start to
create a stronger version of yourself or
vision of yourself that you can then you
can work through
i've
always through my career had um
my own sort of board of
advisors it's an informal thing um when
i'm doing different things where i need
a different point of view or perspective
i'll put people around me and ask them
for advice
mentors sponsors you know fashionable
words that get used but it's really
people that perhaps are a couple of
years ahead of you or older that kind of
done these things before to to learn
from and to be inspired by and to change
them around as well i think those things
those things help
what are your core skills and strengths
um
others will say um
but i think it's around that i start
that i lead with empathy
and that i'm it really matters to me to
understand who the people are that are
that i'm working with and what motivates
them
and
and what doesn't
and to have a different style that can
work with the with each of them to
motivate them to be the very best that
they can be i'm always looking to
understand that
i think i set pretty clear deliverables
and expectations and i really spend the
time with with my core team i absolutely
believe in the frequency of a regular
one-to-one meeting where we can learn
you know to get those constant updates
where i can give
advice but i've always got the clear
north star i've always got written what
i think the deliverables will be i'm not
afraid to pivot
and to change my mind if that i see
evidence and data there's a poster at
wall data wins arguments
i like that because i think it's it's
true that you can really look at
something and know and then if something
isn't going well to stop it and to have
the humility to say we tried something
it didn't work and then to be able to to
move forwards and to role model that as
well and not to be afraid to say i did
that it didn't go so well let's now go
and do let's go and do something else
there's a few of the things others will
add other things i'm sure
also you know to have some fun along the
way i think that's really important i
think when i first started work there
was this thing about works really
serious and it is serious and it matters
but you spend your most amount of time
with the people that you work with and
one of my other favorite posters is that
meetings are made for laughter
and so sometimes if you can just take
the tension out and just break the break
it a little bit i think that's something
that that's important as well
i've heard you um give the advice that
it's important to bring your whole self
to work as well um i think that is some
type that is also kind of counter
narrative in the sense that
people think they should just bring
their professional self to work or their
boss self to work why is it important to
bring your whole self to work
because if you're trying to be
you know other things
you'll just not do a very good job
and if people don't know what else is
going on in your life i mean look at all
the things that we've talked about today
people didn't know i had you know i was
dealing with health issues at different
times and maybe my performance wasn't so
good at that time then i'm going to be
judged unfairly for where i am in that
time as opposed to let's just have an
honest conversation i'm old enough now
i'm 50 but i remember some of the days
of the women that came before that would
leave a handbag and a coat on the back
of a chair to pretend they were still in
the office when actually they popped out
to go and pick up the children or do
something but was scared to show that
because it was a sign of weakness if you
were actually being a mom i mean it
sounds ridiculous but there are still
companies where that sort of behavior is
happening and so the fact that we can be
in 2022 and it's still taboo to talk
about a a disease that you have or it
still can be in certain countries taboo
to talk about the fact that maybe your
parent isn't well or your child isn't i
mean that's crazy so allowing the space
and the culture within companies to to
be who you are and to know the things
that matter to you
ultimately allows people to be higher
performers which ultimately means that
they'll do better in their jobs and
they'll be happier in their lives
and do you think that's a there's a real
responsibility for the leaders at the
top of the organization to
lead by example yeah i i absolutely do
and again here's where the data wins
arguments because if you have more
diverse boards at the tops of companies
you have more successful companies and i
do think there's an element where you
bring where you don't have groupthink
and you have different people around the
table it brings in some of these these
types of ways of being and
ways that form a culture culture is
formed top down and bottom up but so
much of it is from the cues of the
leaders at the top as well so
showing that vulnerability being so open
um
bringing your whole self allows other
people to do so as well
and your career is um
real a real testament to this next piece
of advice which is
about asking
for what you want
people don't do that either because
people think they should take what
they're given but having the
i don't want to use the word courage but
because it doesn't seem like quite the
right word but asking for what you want
is
scary for a lot of people and there's a
lot of threat and risk associated with
that
how has that been important in your
career yeah i think it is but i think
it's also
about doing your homework
knowing what knowing what matters to you
knowing what's important
questioning if these are the things that
matter to you and these are the
opportunities you want this is this pay
rise that you think you should have i
mean my first couple of pay rises
i just said thanks that's great
i mean that's terrible right i had
absolutely no idea of of what my own
worth was and so i just said thank you
um
i never went in in those early pay rise
conversations once a year
reviews to think about was i happy on
the accounts that i was on i just said
thanks i would not give that advice to
anybody
i just wouldn't i think that's a
terrible thing to do i think you should
know those things and then the onus is
on you to make sure you do their
homework on your career because nobody
else is going to do that and also to not
assume that people know what you want
either because sometimes you do know
what you want and you're sat there going
i hope they're going to suggest it and
not to say it people don't do that
because they are scared and again i go
what's the worst that can happen you can
ask for it and they'll say no and then
you've got a judgment call do i want to
stay in a place that said no or are they
giving me a trajectory for what i need
to do in order to get there or actually
is this a wake-up call to say
actually maybe i should look at
something different what do you wish
you'd said in those price conversations
not just thank you but um i've been out
and i've looked at the market and i
understand
now that my value is this and these are
all the things that i've done that i'm
really proud of and that i've been
successful and these were the kpis that
i think that you set me and thus
this is what the equation should be
and then
probably there'd be a bit of a
negotiation but at least i'd be in with
the start right whereas i had and i was
just like thanks
what if your boss turns around and goes
you're out of your mind get out of here
nicola then i think you have to go why
do you think that because if you have
the data to say well other places don't
feel that and here's all the reasons why
i feel passionate and proud of what i'm
doing show me the path that gets me
there and so if it's a yearly pay
conversation maybe look to see if you
could do something in six months or set
out other criteria in terms of what
matters and what's important
a quote from you
the times i've grown the most have been
the times where i felt most nervous the
times that i thought i was i wasn't
going to be able to do it
those growth moments throughout your
career where you felt most nervous
yeah i think well we've talked about
them
the first each of the firsts of the jobs
i think were definitely
um
another one was when i took on my first
position if you like in the industry
which was when i was asked to be
the president of wackol
in the uk which is the women in
advertising communications of london
club it's a 100 year old networking club
for women in the in the industry that's
gone through its own metamorphosis and
so suddenly i'd gone from being nicola
in
um you know just in an agency to having
this position across the industry to
inspire women to bring women together
and to
chart what it means to be part of a a
women's club
in this era and what needs there might
be
and so yeah i practiced i prepped i
really thought long and hard a lot of
the things that we talked about i went
and met all the past presidents i got
the advice from them as to what they
wanted i talked to existing members what
they wanted so i really did my homework
so that when i came to that moment of
setting out my vision for for the year
um as to what i was going to do i felt
prepped i was still nervous
it's good to have those nerves right but
yeah do the prep and i think it helps
those nerves a lot of people they tell
themselves a story about those navs the
story being
i'm an imposter
and i imposter syndrome seems to be such
a frequently asked question of me and
from this audience is like how do you
deal with that people think i think they
think that impos that feeling of nerves
which is that i think that they're
reading into feeling like an imposter is
signed to retreat and to get back into
comfort
get back into certainty
no for me it's it's a rush of adrenaline
it's the it's the moment before you do
something to go
all right you've done the prep you've
got this it's good just to kind of
get ready it's like a getting ready
moment and then you go
and then it kind of helps it helps you
go there because i think if perhaps it
doesn't happen then maybe you're not
going to be on your a-game and maybe
that's not a good thing
do you sleep with the phone by the bed
um in and out is the honest answer in
and out so i was really good when the
kids were younger about putting it um
into into the hallway and as i've
started to travel more it is a bit too
near if i'm honest um because i'm doing
that excuse of it serves as my alarm
clock
because i heard you say that you keep
you advised people to keep a physical
alarm clock yeah even though they made
them which we have yes no we've got them
in certainly at home we've got them but
if i'm on the road yeah it's definitely
next to me
i had a few words to say about one of my
sponsors on this podcast the tectonic
plates in which we build our business
can shift overnight and with the world
we live in getting increasingly more
digital it's never been more important
to be connected and that's why i've
partnered with vodafone business they
offer reliable and critical connectivity
to run your business their network is
even used by core services such as the
police and the nhs and the ambulance
service because it's unbelievable their
broadband comes with a minimum
guaranteed speed as well which is
something i think i wish i'd had
throughout my career so you're never
lagging behind and on top of this they
give you all of that sort of extensive
business expertise you need when you
need it to learn more about how to find
the right type of connectivity tailored
for your small business along with free
resources insights and one-on-one advice
from digital advisors search v-hub by
vodafone
and you know this um this book i have
here make it work lessons from life in
business she means business now she
means business is a joint initiative
between facebook and the federation of
small businesses
and the british chamber of commerce
to encourage uh female entrepreneurship
why is that so important to you
so she means business is something that
we set up in 2016 in the uk but it's
actually now something that runs all
around the world and it's a a
matter-enabled program which is to
basically encourage more women to set up
businesses because women actually set up
businesses at half the rate that men do
and so in the last five six years we've
now trained over a million and a half
women
equipping them with digital skills
giving them new networks to be able to
get out there and to feel confident in
setting up their businesses
the reason this matters is i mean
there's so many reasons it's important
to me because you know being a mum of a
girl as well as three boys i want gabby
to have exactly the same opportunities
as you know my boys do
and so much of society has said that
can't be so whether it comes to the
allocation of funding for businesses
getting set up whereas you look for role
models out there and so this book we
created was deliberately designed for
people younger in career to be able to
look up because the
importance of relatable role models is
so so important if you can see someone
just above you that's done it
then it will give you the inspiration to
think well maybe i could do something
like that too
and so this book brings together
very successful business leaders but
also women that are just starting out
with with new businesses as well the
likes that have come from instagram the
creators like
you know grace beverly who i you know i
know you know and have and have
interviewed so that they can see that it
could be possible for them to do so and
they share their advice they share their
top tips they share the things they wish
they'd have known in order to inspire
the the next generation and this is just
not a nice thing to do
this is something alison rose who is the
ceo of nat west bank she did something
called the rose review and she said that
if women were to set up businesses at
the rate that men are setting them up it
would add 250 billion pounds to the
economy
so
we need these women
we need these women to go out and set up
businesses and honestly it's one of the
the best things that i get to do in my
job is to go meet these women that have
set up businesses and have been
empowered because of because of our
platforms
what are the the um barriers in their
way
um for to to close the gap on that
disparity and i'm thinking of this also
from the context as a
male employer
what what what how can i be more of an
ally and supportive to
my colleagues who are women who might be
a victim at certain times to like
unconscious biases
like what can i do
you can call it out i mean one of the
things that we see more than anything
around around a table is look for the
woman who's not speaking i mean
sometimes they even physically do it
they don't take the seat at the table
sheryl sandberg talks about this you
know on the lean in it's like first of
all make sure you're actually sat round
the table don't take one of the seats
that are at the back of the room
then if you're not hearing from
different people this was really
noticeable through the pandemic on zoom
the people that just sat there and were
quiet i think that the onus actually
should be on the leader to say i'd love
to hear your point of view on that what
do you think and invite them into the
conversation
i think
having more senior women in a company
tell their story and make an intentional
space
for the younger women in in korea to be
able to hear those are the things that i
think are
also important and then for you to say
well you didn't get it right where you
might have had moments where you had
your own learning moment that you're not
afraid to to share
and give resources give resources i mean
whackle does an amazing
amazing training day every year where
you come and you just listen and you
laugh and you cry and you're inspired by
the women that are basically sharing
their stories
in the research um i read that you'd
found that women's confidence falls
between their late 20s and their 30s
pretty significantly
why is that
yeah there's there's a lot of things
that are going on um at that time and it
goes back to
it's a time where a lot of women drop
out
it happens to do with um having babies
maternity etc and again as an employer
having strong policies in this area
you create the most loyal of you know of
talent that wants to come back if they
feel that they've been part of it i've
promoted women than when they've been on
maternity leave on a regular basis
because they think if you've got top
talent just because they're out for a
few months doesn't mean that they
shouldn't be rewarded for what's gone on
before so having those behaviors that
people see
but it's actually not just about the
women as well it's about the men if
you've got paternity policies i remember
a conversation i had with with one of my
senior leaders
where he hadn't taken his paternity
leave and i said to him if you don't
take your leave
none of the men that work for you will
be able to do that he really didn't want
to do it i sort of had to force him
and he took his time i took a couple of
months and he came back after he said
thank you he said if you hadn't said
that to me i wouldn't have done it and
honestly it was the very best thing i
could have done for me and my family and
he said i'm going to talk about that as
a learning moment for himself but also
to give you know the guys
a moment ago you're not going to get
fired if you go on paternity leave
that's going to be okay
on that point of parenting one of the
things that i i'm definitely um guilty
of on this podcast is is asking that
question about balance about work-life
balance and i've heard you talk about
this there's when i ask that question
there's definitely
a presumption that things must be out of
balance and i've heard you say that
that's not a great question to ask so i
thought okay i'll stop asking that
question but you've asked it now because
you've raised it
i watched the video upstairs of you
saying that i thought [ __ ] i've i've um
i've been asking everybody that question
about balance why is that such a bad
question to be asking
it's a bad question to ask because it's
normally only asked to women yeah my
husband who also has four children and a
big job has never been asked that
question ever and he does conferences
and podcasts and all the rest of it so
it's a woman's question and the
assumption behind and the bias is that
if i have a job then i must be a bad mom
that's really and so even the simplest
of things like that is a bias that we
have to call out because it just puts
another level of guilt onto the woman
that she doesn't need to have now if you
say how you know you can ask the
question in a different way top tips for
these things etc
um and in many ways that's been the
nature of the whole of this conversation
but it's that one just it just hurts me
i i i raise it because i have to and i
remember one of my guests
made a very similar point and they said
no one's ever asked joe rick joe wicks
who's got i think he's got three kids
now he's good friend of mine three kids
i think he's got four on the way um how
he does it
how'd you do it all joe how'd you do it
all right no one's ever asked him that
and it's completely true it was a real
moment for me like [ __ ] that's so true
there's a real uh i don't know there's a
real
prejudice i guess there there's a real
assumption there which is really
really unhelpful
and it's a sign of a broader kind of
bias that exists in our society
well you know when you look you look
forward at the next chapter of your own
life
there's so much
change going on you're such an innately
curious person
what do you foresee what what are you i
know i hate to assume that people can
configure it all out in um
in advance but what kind what do you see
in the next chapter of your own life
so
well i'll start with the deeply personal
um which is that i hope that i will be
blessed to be lucky enough to to be a
grandma at some point and i'm saying now
kids if you're listening no pressure get
there in your own time but
family is really important to me and i
think there is no one richer than
someone that has a multi-generational
family so
i hope that i will be blessed
i
hope
that through the work of the foundation
that we've created to
find a cure for follicular lymphoma that
we will find cure cures in my lifetime
um that matters hugely um to me
and then i
i look forward to you too you and i
doing another one of these in the future
where we're doing it in the metaverse
from different parts of the world
and we're doing things together that we
never dreamed that we might be able to
with all the foresight that we have with
the knowledge and intelligence and the
awareness of what we see
that actually will be even more
extraordinary when this fully realized
version is built and i know you're going
to be in there and i know you're going
to have a world that's going to be all
singing and all dancing you'll have your
dining room in there yeah i'm looking
forward to visiting if you'll have me
of course i'll have you thank you
we have a closing tradition on this
podcast where the last guest
asks the next next guest i know i'm
nervous about this
sometimes we have some some very easy
questions so
um
is there something
you associate
with a key moment
of hardship in your life
a certain song
playlist
smell
food
that takes you back to that moment it's
a strange one actually
it's a pair of soft tracksuit bottoms of
all things because
to have a pet scan you need comfy
clothing
and you need things without um
metal in it
and i didn't have a pair of sweatpants
that had that
and so i had to actually go and buy some
on the day before on that sunday before
the monday
and so whenever i see them and they're
in the bottom of the wardrobe it does
just take me back to that moment and so
yeah who'd have thought pair of
sweatpants
do you keep them in the wardrobe yeah
they are there i didn't throw them away
it's quite weird that i haven't thrown
them away right
you've ever considered throwing them
away no hasn't occurred to me maybe i'm
gonna go home now and actually chuck
them in the bin
i'll leave that choice to you nicola
thank you so much for your time
i know how important that is um to
everybody but
especially someone who's
who's so incredibly
successful in is is is has this huge
company to to to drive forward thank you
so much for your honesty your wisdom
your vulnerability all of it is so
incredibly important and the the work
that it does for the listener um the the
value that it brings to the listener the
value that it brings to to me as someone
that gets to interviewing you and pick
your brain is is hard to quantify you
are you are i mean you are just a a
one-of-a-kind inspiration to so many i
know you're a huge inspiration to gabby
who is upstairs because i've heard i've
had that talked about as well and to so
many others i actually messaged my team
beforehand and said and i've never done
this before i said nikola's coming you
all need to make sure you hear this so
i'm sure they're riddled up and down
this building on all the screens we have
up and down this building watching and
i've never done that before i said this
i think the quote was um you'll never be
able to get um this kind of um
business advice leadership experience
regardless of what you paid for it so
make sure you're all tuned into this one
and i really really mean that you're
you're a tremendous inspiration for so
many reasons and you buck so many
important narratives that have to be
booked you buck so many narratives that
have to be booked and one of them is
just your style you know this this idea
that you've you've led with empathy and
empathy can take us to the top is i
think an important message to hear
because sometimes we we think that we've
gotta be a little bit more nefarious in
order to climb in our careers and you're
a shining example that that is not true
so thank you for the inspiration thank
you for your time thank you for your
openness and thank you for being here
today
thank you for having me um
it's been
it's been emotional i have to say thank
you thank you
as you might know crafted one of the
sponsors of this podcast and crafted are
a jewelry brand and they make really
meaningful pieces of jewelry and this
piece by crafted when i put it on for me
it represents courage it represents
ambition it represents being calm and
loving and respectful and nurturing
while also being the antithesis of that
seemingly the antithesis of that which
is um sometimes a little bit aggressive
with my goals and determined and
courageous and brave the really
wonderful thing about crafty jewellery
is it's super affordable it looks
amazing the pieces hold tremendous
meaning and they are really well made
[Music]
[Music]
you